[Music]
this may look like a space mission
control center but it's actually a major
european fruit and vegetable auction in
belgium
it is run by bell orta one of the
largest fruit and veg selling
cooperatives in europe
every day up to four thousand tons of
fresh produce are sold here the
organization has strict produce
procedures to ensure good quality
standards and prices
for growers sustainable production also
means a fair income
we aim for the best possible price in
the markets
for the production of our growers we
also want to let the consumer enjoy our
fresh produce in a healthy way
if you want to build trust of the
consumer of even our buyers
and the production of our growers then
you're also looking at long-term
relationship between what happens on the
field what happens at the producer side
and what happens
at the consumer's home
fair market conditions sustainable
farming and quality standards are some
of the pillars of the eu's new common
agricultural policy cap its future goals
are to combine social economic and
environmental approaches to create a
sustainable model of european
agriculture
let's leave the auction and head to two
farms in puta and hala that are part of
the burlotta network
both farms have made changes to make
their production more sustainable thanks
to financial support from the cap
under this huge greenhouse where
thousands of tomato plants grow nothing
goes to waste
a cogeneration system produces
complementary energy which is released
into the local grid
thermal insulation screens help save
heat at night natural methods are used
to protect plants from disease and the
irrigation system ensures the most
efficient use of water
the water
the excess water is collected and after
it's purified
it is reused on the plants
so it's a closed cycle nothing goes to
waste
we also use the maximum amount of rain
in order to meet our water requirements
as efficiently as possible
also efficient
a led lighting system installed in the
greenhouse helps compensate the lack of
light during winter months
the advantage of led lights is that they
consume less power so we save energy
and we can also provide optimal light
for the plants needed
farms of all sizes are playing an
important role in the transition towards
a more eco-friendly agriculture
sustainable solutions like those used in
putter's tomato production are also used
in this family-owned strawberry farm in
hala
[Music]
they apply natural remedies to protect
plants from disease as well as using new
technology like this autonomous robot
that uses uv light to fight powdery
mildew it's a machine that helps reduce
the use of pesticides
we mainly use a natural strategy
we use organic and natural methods as
much as we can to fight plant diseases
only as a last option do we use
chemicals
of course it is important that we all
make these efforts because in the end it
does affect our final product there is
also a growing demand from consumers for
more environmentally friendly and
pesticide free fruits
[Music]